Thank You drum for joining us this is
the first live podcast webinar on
Australian time so I'm then as Andrews
already pointed out I'm not in the
cupboard under the stairs Harry Potter
style I'm in the living room this
morning because it's a sick at 7:00 a.m.
and everyone else is asleep at the
moment so I've been forced into the
living room and but really excited to
have you all here and got some great
panelists and we're gonna really have an
open honest conversation about how
they've been finding things in the crazy
times that rule living in right now and
just just a bit of housekeeping so where
where is about has just messaged all of
you guys can chat in there and answer
the questions that we may ask you and
then also what you'll see is a Q&A tab
so a huge part of today is going to be
about answering your questions I want to
make sure that we get your questions
answered so you should see there that
I've put in that Q&A tab but ask your
questions here and when you see
someone's question come through you can
click up vote and that's just basically
going to indicate to me that that's a
question that you definitely want our to
get answered and it's a popular question
so as we're talking please feel free to
submit your questions but as all of you
have registered you've also submit your
questions as well so I've got those
prepared and we're going to be asking
those questions so before we start let's
start with a very quick intro Belinda if
you go first and let everyone know who
you are what you've been up to the
market that you recruit in and yeah and
then we can do the the other chaps as
well yeah sure so anybody that doesn't
know I run an agency called focus group
it's fairly new it's only two years old
and we recruit heavily in tech digital
talent we also do sales as well but our
niche is essentially tech and digital
okay what about clients our startup
tech companies that you know have
founded in America and that want to tap
into the Australian market so companies
like kwon-do OpenTable epic car that was
just acquired by MasterCard recently
Telstra belong just to kind of name a
few and we do a lot of their contracting
roles temporals as well as permanent
roles okay laughing covin has been super
interesting luckily enough we've been
kind of pivoting in angles in many ways
but we're so lucky that we're in tech
because as you know Tech is kind of like
a thriving market right now yeah so
we've had a bunch of roles come in from
contracting from temporals
permanent has died but we can talk more
about pivoting we have launched a course
which is a LinkedIn 90-day
transformation course for our clients so
we actually transform their LinkedIn
profiles create personal branding is for
the sales and marketing team and we
charge a retainer model for that and
that's working really well we'll
definitely dive into those things
nothing that's really interested in a
couple of questions of definitely a
couple of questions come through on how
people pivoting and how they're adapt
and so we're definitely Vince I was
really interested in well pleasure
having you here Jason having one entry
entry info yourself next thanks for sure
yeah as their as the name place says my
name is Jason Ralston and I've been
recruiting from nine years this month
tomorrow month I company now called
Blackrock and we are a multidisciplinary
recruitment and we doing some exec
search only new the same Linda's come
here only to his doll we got at the
moment that whole thing that staff
there's about four five
tres is breaking up a bit there you
break out and I might say 4000 how's
that I'm any good now yeah other years
okay we heard most of that we didn't
break under FY yeah children now you're
a you did break up a look yeah yeah
thank you and pleasure having you here
and really great to meet you me as I
said I am when I think my first in
recruitment I saw your quiff all over my
LinkedIn feed mate of your content
you're smashing it how early days videos
of you on the phone this development
calls a lot so and I'm looking forward
to it Andrew like the bull dandruff
suggest I have definitely been in
recruitment for longer and 14 years in
counted so what that director for
designing build and design and build 15
years or 16 years now we've got 40 team
members across Melbourne and Sydney and
pretty it's broken up between private
sector into the construction engineering
and property space and then I've said
the public sector space as well okay um
but it's lovely to see you show you a
beautiful man all this is your picture
up there suggesting yet thank you for
that time I look up there I get
inspiration so it's love you right cool
so before we go into the questions that
people submitted what while and ask you
guys that the first thing is what what
some covert 19 taught you so far
professionally or personally don't have
a baby at the same time
I never baby the same time varible idea
okay anything else or is that is that
what you're going for and is that always
taught you said it all seriousness for
me you know every day is a new day in
recruiting generally without covert 19
being here and I think what it's taught
me already is that um be proud of what
you've achieved you know don't forget
that you've got to a certain place in
your career webinar you've done it for
one two or five years yeah remember that
we all need downturns we all need to
experience these sort of things because
it makes us better what we are who we
are
yeah so I think what's taught me is that
you know what your skin is tough it is
hard but at the same time just retain a
little bit perspective that this is now
but there'll be a new reality in three
months time in six months time so don't
be too disheartened by the fact that
we're going through this right now
because there's another side to it and
there's light at the end of the tunnel
absolutely like and Belinda what about
you what was it it has taught me that
content is king okay that is what I mean
by that is I've been creating content
for the agency for about a year now and
a lot of people were questioning I guess
why I was doing that at scale and how it
actually was bringing value to the
recruitment industry and it's funny now
since you know the curve in a lot of
people are creating content and are
forced to go online in a digital world
to be able to create personal brands for
their recruitment consultants and for
the agency to be able to pivot to get in
front of a bigger audience right so I
definitely think Co vid has taught me
that content creation is is winning for
sure okay interesting we're definite
I've into that Jason what about you my
friend what was it taught you so far
yeah I am I think both will in this term
what if Andrew said I think this down
then definitely makes honest companies
and honest people I vote cells honest
operators it carry on with too much fat
in the balance sheet and Ciara later
will find you out yeah
look a lot of things but more more more
specifically you know no take things for
granted as well obviously from a life
perspective but from a business
perspective if you've got a lot logic
rule a little more than a motion times
like that I think I think the
conversations that I've been having in
in with UK businesses I think times like
this it definitely gives you perspective
on and a bit of reality check if you've
been caught in the game of the sort of
headcount vanity of your recruitment
business rather than the sort of bottom
line sanity and I think that's that'll
definitely put into perspective for a
lot of people but okay so um some of the
questions that I'd really be keen to
dive into so just to set the scene
Andrew how many how many people do you
manage and Jason likewise oh and Belinda
also and like what what the saw teams
and how many people you're responsible
for if any yeah so I suppose from
Sydney's perspective there are 20 team
members Melbourne a perspex if there's
eleven twelve and design and build in
their names in public setup okay I
manage every single one of them up a
leadership teaming and both offices that
are relying on heavily okay I'm so yeah
they're you know doing the grunt work so
to speak in terms of the day-to-day the
consultants and I Loxley catch-up their
leadership room I think would be your
question okay no that's great that's
good for for me and a good contest Jason
what about yourself yeah there's about
fifteen in Brisbane and then Billy
that's okay and then Belinda is it just
do you is it you and your business
partner or what's the no so we've got
five people and we
affiliate partners to resource for us so
we actually have a different model I
guess to a 360 recruiter agency well so
usually I do all the beanie and one of
my partners and we use resources to
purely just build up the candidate
portfolio to send out to clients so
there's about five of us in total and
then we have three people that do all of
our content filming editing okay perfect
so you mentioned business development
let's start there because that was one
of the much common and popular questions
that people asked so it's the question
that came through from Craig white was
what are your key strategy is right now
for developing business in an economic
downturn into what's going on right now
so I guess even through what you're
saying for your leadership team and your
guys or tissue personally how have you
guys found developing business or your
people developing business and how
they've gone about it oh yeah if you
want to go oh yeah you started talking
so it's all on you now okay so for me I
actually used to do it a bunch of cold
calling and prospecting and you know I
guess relationship building or the
lunches and dining I think relationships
in Melbourne most definitely here it's
all about building relationships and
maintaining those but what I found
since covered and obviously I guess
three months before coronavirus happened
is the content that I've been creating
is essentially feeding why we create
content because it gives us an audience
or gets us in front of people that
probably would never answer my call or
never would work with us you know down
the truck or even before so an example
was I created a video two weeks before
kovat and we had a big client reach out
to us on my dear
message me he's live was literally
you're on LinkedIn every day you are in
my feet every time I open my LinkedIn
profile we have to work with you much
and then we met and we won the deal so I
think content has helped us at scale to
BT but we also do the old-school way of
like you know reaching out and email
marketing you know cold calling
referrals you know just conversation
building network as well so and that
that's still working like you're gay
that's that that's been that's just
still working for you with what's going
on right now in terms of a business
development including clients clients
are putting everything on hold so I
think 85% of our roles right now are on
hold we're actually not placing yeah
that's on the home side on the pamp side
yeah contracting by um we're still
reaching out to people we're still
asking if they need help or any
assistance is there anything we can do
right now to give value to your team or
to your company to really just help with
support marketing it's not about your
selling right now it's about supporting
the crank that we have and you know
building those relationships again so a
lot of content has been a new BT way for
any of you guys actually this is a
really good tool that we use is an
agency it's called vidyard yeah that's
like an odd row yeah videos it's free
it's a Chrome extension that you can
attach on your LinkedIn profile and you
can actually send messages in a video
format on the DIMM that's awesome it's
free as well check out Jason Andrew what
about you if your team your leaders or
yourself how how do you find a business
velopment right now and how are you
approaching it I think we have to
remember that as a society there's one
thing that we love to do as human beings
it doesn't matter if you're a doctor a
nurse a soldier a recruiter which is
that we love to gossip we love to go to
any social we want to talk right so
for the most part people are always too
busy to talk too busy doing too many
different things so in a time like this
when there's a common enemy such as co19
you can just generally pick up the phone
and say hey how you going in Australia
in particular how you going because
ticking well and don't say you're you
know what I've been amazed moved to a
certain extent is that people have
picking up the phone and just asking how
you go and I think also consider that
recruitment isn't picked up the phone
and getting a job recruitment is picking
up the phone and start in a relationship
you know someone's always got to make
the first move I mean it's up to us to
do that so we don't necessarily say hey
how you going what you're looking for
right now it's more about hey how are
you going how are you finding things at
the moment what's happened in your work
and generally speaking when people are
going through the level of crises and
whatever else they've kind of one event
they want to talk about it and in fact
the feedback that African songs has been
Jesus actually people are picking up the
phone for the first time in two years
it's like yeah yeah you've got a common
enemy so it's okay to pick up the phone
but don't think you're gonna get a job
on the other side of it you know just
start the conversation and then work it
from there but if you think you're gonna
get a job in every call you ain't gonna
get it
so have you communicated that then and
the expectations have now changed on
what a successful business development
call s well it's never the first folks I
think if you get a job in the first call
of any client they're not going to be a
long-term client cuz they'll probably
give that job to anyone okay and I'm
really the best clients are the one that
you have to work on over a period of
time yeah I think it's better to get
other information related to the client
in just a job this kind of if you picked
up the phone and they say hey here's a
job you've not really found out a lot
about their business and you kind of
want to have to work for it so I would
say um you know we've spoken to the guys
about what's important in terms of what
does the client want from us it's not
what's in it for us is you pick up the
phone and say hey what do you want for
me and then start doing what you're told
what you're doing what they've asked you
did it and that's always think that a
train of thought so yeah like I said I'm
in summary I think client development
work is easier than ever before yeah
it's been it's been human empathetic
checking in with people as ago and like
just just having those conversations and
yeah just building those relationships
rather than
right how can I get a job at this phone
call yeah that ain't gonna be the way
that's the quickest way to spell use
them insanity in a sense you're just
gonna do yourself up in that if that's
what success looks like you're setting
the wrong jobs okay
nice Jason anything to add how have your
guys been finding biz development how
they've been approached net yes we we've
decreased the amount of calls how do we
expect from God
we've increased the amount of time on
Owen I'm naturally that's a first then a
talk I said still the contents on
windows touched on I've been doing that
for years now and and you know finding
new ways to offer offer help and you
know that allow people to want to our
counters at set times and and don't get
get helping service on all sorts of
different things potential improvement
but yeah
less less let us look no no harder Sonny
probably would do on the business cycle
bit more so yeah fine it has been a long
run on the phone from home they're not
getting chased down by their boss for
that a lot of people know when eyes open
so you get more time to find the people
you get to find out a lot more people so
just yeah Anderson today okay I like it
so one of the questions that Paul
Jenkins put it through is so how do you
stay connected with clients without
annoying them in a slow market it's like
once you once you've checked in what
we're doing after that do you not I mean
so how how have you guys maintain those
touch points and so continued yeah after
you've got free to that person checked
in then watching I mean how are you how
are you or your guys staying connected
with your clients
for us now it's all about the
follow-through so you have a
conversation you see you listen to
somebody do that which reminds me I've
got to do something I've got to do that
for someone right now but I'm
follow-through so there will always be
one for briefings out of a 40-minute 30
40 minute call that you can pick as a
next checkpoint
to follow up on so that's what a lot of
our guys have been doing wrong Matt and
so for brilliant at that from here Wow
from our company and so you're just
picking things on call you can you can
serve users follow up or follow throughs
and actually go through ok I like it
well Andrew blatant anything to add to
that what are you going what you guys
doing to ensure you're staying connected
in front of mind yeah I'm having enough
touch points send in touch with me all
right one of the things that you know
you find with you know colleagues that
you work with through the years now you
know recruitment professionals in
general is that I can follow up their
lack of consistency and I think again
that's expectation sending about what
you're trying to get from the first
second third fourth fifth six I think
whatever form you're going to make
bowling for and what you said you're
gonna do but I think also you know if
you're a smart business and you've got a
lot of content you kind of want to start
getting them into a bit of a Content
stream where you're sharing content that
you promote it on your social sites and
sharing that with your clients but
they're thinking about the point as well
so if your client is a health and safety
manager don't share content in relation
to architecture design gives me the
greatest respect they ain't going to be
interested but if you're sharing content
with them is relevant to health and
safety they could kind of start to pay
notice than that so think about the
content you're sharing because there's
plenty of content out there and you know
design and building you know we're proud
of the content you create you know we've
got 50,000 followers now and you know we
try and post content pretty much every
day but they look at what content
engages your network look at the
click-through rates look at your
impressions
your engagement and then start to curate
that over a period of two to four weeks
and they share that with your clients
because that one's that engaging the
network socially that would do the same
in the clients but most of all just do
what you're bloody told you know trust
Trust takes time to build and your
opportunity in that first pool is to
main you know start you know an
impression on someone or a reception but
how you they're not after that leaves
the impression so if they say look don't
call me or this time don't call them the
next week or send him a CV of some
random a week later because that ain't
gonna work
do what you're told and generally what I
found was even when starting Sydney in
2012 starting on recruitment Korea
condoms like call me every six weeks and
then towards the six-month one-year
point they were happy to hear from me
for a bit more a bit more frequently but
I've done what I was told and I think
sometimes you will you know what we're
nine bishops we want to do well and
succeed we're also a bit impatient and I
don't think impatience right now will
actually wash it at all of anyone yeah
no that's good
I think I'm so we've spoken about
content a lot right so let's talk about
this for a second because there might be
a lot of people watching this that have
never made a piece of content ever and
you're saying look content content
content right which which I get and also
I'm I'm in that game as well but just
how always think about it is with this
with the question that hopefully I'll
pronounce this right but Hina I hate him
so if I pronounced that wrong so she
asked a really interesting question I
think contents part of the answer to
this it'd be good to get your thoughts
in this so she asked within Sydney when
this is all over and what picks up
clients are hiring and there will likely
be a scramble from all recruiter to
represent and place stronger candidates
who've been made redundant or a back on
the market and also yeah things are
moving more how do I give myself the
edge the self edge over my competitors
in being a candidate go-to recruiter I
guess a lot of people be thinking about
that right now how can I ensure that I'm
front of mind I'm the person that people
call or go to be when this time pick
them up again personally I think of the
content
part of that let's talk a bit about that
and we can go into that but what are you
what are your thoughts on that how come
recruiters make sure that they're the
go-to when we start bouncing back out of
it because everyone's going to be one in
- yeah it's going to be a busy time
hopefully for a lot of people but yeah
what do we think about that what's that
sorry really want to fraud - when you
asked but Belinda got what about you
oversleep I know that who's gonna speak
say no I definitely think going back to
personal branding it's about building a
personal brand and this goes for all
consultants you know out there or even
like owners and agencies they should all
be building a brand because brand always
stays and as you know content creation
LinkedIn is organic it's free but if you
want to take it to the next step you can
start putting funds aside for marketing
budgets where you can organize a
business manager and start paying for
ads like Facebook Ads Instagram stories
Instagram ads pushing it up to the right
audience and actually narrowing
narrowing it down to who you want to
target whatever your industry is so I
definitely think it's about building a
personal brand and sharing the pieces of
content that you're doing on LinkedIn
Instagram Facebook into messages of
potential clients that may that may add
value to that client or that candidate
in that industry so I definitely think
it's content at scale as you know you
probably agree Hashem but yeah
definitely building a personal brand and
awareness in that industry to be known
as like the thought leader okay so I
think you're going to okay right so so
far more if I'm watching this right now
and I've never made a piece of content
and like okay wrong I listen to these
guys I'm seeing I've got more time on my
hands I'm gonna start cranking content
what's your sort of go-to because I'm
sure you get asked this quite
all the time I'm worried about blending
in with the coronavirus noise don't talk
about coronavirus I've I might have
posted about my work from home setup
I've done that post so what where do I
start
what's just will go to advice for that I
think you need to start you know that's
why you need to start reading like
articles in your industry so for me I'm
in tech and digital I follow a lot of
Business Insider articles TechCrunch a
few HR tech articles as well where I get
a lot of my topics and ideas from I also
follow what's happening in the industry
or I reach out to recruiters just
conversation having conversation when
you start doing content everything is
thought in content so me having this
conversation now there's topics that I
could talk about in my next post next
week on LinkedIn having a conversation
with you guys it's about having
conversations with people in the
industry and reading about topics in
your industry to create content you know
that may add value to that person but
it's definitely hard to pick topics I
agree but it's about reading more that's
what's happening in your industry to be
able to create more content okay so okay
that's that's interesting Andrew what
yeah what are you I'm sure you're
speaking to your people about this like
how how and what should people be doing
to ensure that they're the recruiter
that people call when they starts
picking up I sort of break it down in
terms of personal brand and you know
what are the things that you want to be
seen as and so I think you want to be
seen as a specialist yeah I'm gonna be
seeing with dedicate you want to be seen
as knowledgeable you want to be seen as
informed you want to be seen as well
networked but it's all well and good to
be seen as that you need to back it up
so you want to stand that from the
ground think about when people go and
buy products generally speaking they buy
off the back of a referral from somebody
else so if you haven't got testimonials
from your previously based candidates
and you haven't got clients giving you
references and giving your testimonials
but you want to stand out that's where
you want to start because ultimately
people want to know that what they're
buying from you
there's a level of you know it's been
references you know people know that
this respect is trusted and you've got
that to back it up
and because like I said earlier I think
you can build perception of people on
branding and I think it's great but it's
the impression that you leave that's
what yeah that's what Rand is so you
know we talked to the guys a lot about
well every single person you placed in a
role why they not recommended you on
LinkedIn because we are listed you they
should be able to do that for you've
done the right thing by then that's
where it's got to be same with the
appliance it will continue doing the
right thing by then they should be they
want to help you survive in this market
so you can fly with the other side you
know you prefer to my LinkedIn you know
I wanted I don't do much recruitment
anymore yeah I'm failing miserably at
the moment at it I asked everyone for a
recommendation but then I was on
LinkedIn in 2006 on Facebook so nope my
age but you if you want to stand out
you've got to help people stand you out
you've got to get references and so the
remains your profile in that manner and
that's sort of what we've been talking
about to the guys is it's great saying
it you know I've got a back wall that
where's your capability statement
where's your evidence to back it up yeah
now really like that so yeah remain
invisible personal brand content is
definitely part of how you can ensure
that you're the person that people call
when things don't pick them up and then
also as you said are you someone that
genuinely cared about these people
during this difficult time I use someone
that full Jason said and actually
deliver on the way you're still trying
to be perceived online so you can you
can be found got you one comment away
from being found out right which is
which is the the great thing about I
think and Jason anything to add or I'll
hit you with in a career okay I like
that so Jason what I wanted to ask you
and then I'd love to get and whoever
guys talking it's no another real
popular question that came through from
different people was remaining motivated
and or keep your team motivated I think
I've definitely struck I'd have good
days and bad days with this work from
home as you can tell I'm in the living
room under
under a staircase so you can get a bit
difficult sometimes but like how have
you how have you been sort of how have
you been trying to make sure that you
keep your team motivated and or even
yourself what comes up for you when you
still can't hear me can you not what we
can he make weakness or yeah we can hear
you fine for me is a structure so
working in real estate when I got out of
high school the biggest ball is the list
is you know the people that I have
acquired to be like and on a building
some of them like and and so on so all
have really good structure to that a
very disciplined and whenever they're
not feeling great or they're not getting
the results that they want they they
fall back with a nice cool routines my
my parents my mother used to always push
me into that at school and I still think
that was there I don't need to do that
because mom owns them when I'm a kid but
yeah I learned and listened I learned
that the routine and having a good
structure to your day was the framework
that success it's one of the most
underrated strategies I personal okay
and let okay definitely and I think also
just in times like this getting dressed
as well health
what what so what what were the tip what
are the typical types of structures that
you're encouraging people today to do
right now or what does a typical
structure look like falling your
concerns right now or even for yourself
that might be good for people on how how
you're structuring things yeah so we're
rolling it through one or two other
teams here and might be through through
everyone it's up to them but there's a
group here that they're doing
universally predict that means
trying to hit the what we call the
LeBron challenge and it's eight hours
and I allow the truck as much deep sleep
as we can Goodrem but you want to get as
close to us or there about the first
eight hours to sleep yet I know people
gonna say that's not optimal for
everyone but for us but we start there
so you know one down sort of eight nine
o'clock get to bed early and then you
can you know allows you to wake up and
so the start well I've experimented what
different things over the past few years
I've been to Paris span and what I've
found is some sleep just has is that for
me and for love people I know is a key
catalyst in sort of eating right
thinking right acting right etc yeah see
I'm gonna wake up I have an hour hour
gap between not going on LinkedIn or
checking inbox or go on social or
returning any text messages and just do
some headspace meditation three five
five ten minutes for a war just briefly
but back into cycling so just I don't
want to go into too much there but
that's there about so where I start I
think I'll get obviously Billington and
real or focus on this but I think what's
great about that Jason in your making
sure that you're getting the work-life
balance right it like this like for me
personally I I've worked I've said a
couple times now I've worked in every
single room of this house besides the
bathroom what I've done really difficult
lease witching off so so you're right so
obviously I walk into the kitchen after
I've finished work and I've worked there
all day so do not I mean whereas before
when I would left the office that's when
I left work and I found that quite easy
to do because there was that just
experience with walk and leaving the
office going home and then that small I
was going to be just found that easier
to be present but I've definitely found
that harder but I loved all the things
that you shared there on how many
pyramid business owners tell people to
sleep okay enough to get enough sleep so
I think that's the great thing to
advocate to be an advocate brought but
Andrew what about you how obviously as
you said you've got your leadership team
how how how you communicate into your
guys and people want to they're gonna
have to keep their team as motivated
which I know can be difficult with
what's going on right now so what's what
what the conversations that you'll have
them with people yeah I'll come on to
that is sick well obviously Jason it's
funny talking about sleep but I think
I've had about four hours in the last
six days yeah that's great and two
things my tactics I think at the end of
the day write down what you're grateful
for recruiter or not is clover 19 or
whether or not it's its pre GFC best
time of your life generally ninety
percent of the time you're not winning
you know unfortunately we loo nitaac sin
a way but you don't always win so right
I don't think they'd be grateful for
that but also right that means you're
grateful in life there are related to
recruitment because there's plenty of
good things happen in the world yeah I'm
I think you know in terms of mental
health and you know I do meditate I do
have a morning routine I do that every
morning subjects when the baby gets me
there's certainly structures that I try
and implement but I say to anyone you
know at the end of the day just make
sure you write them what's happened
today because there is good in it and in
fact your brains are trained to look for
the negative because the media are
absolute bastards and they have to do
that ya know if you start practicing
what's good in the world what will
happen in be days you'll find better
things to like that good things then it
just starts to happen naturally where do
you feel about the bat all you think
about is the bad so I encourage people
to do that and that's the sort of
structure we've implemented with the
team leaders and the teams is will do
morning catch ups in relation to what's
on for the day and then we'll do sort of
an afternoon sort of hey let us know how
your day's going but let us know well
don't worry about the bat [ __ ] because
you know what is what it is I'm right
down what has happened today and then
look at the potential in that so that's
sort of what we've tried to implement
and it for the most part is it's going
relatively well um don't get me wrong I
think we'll look back in there will be
things that we could have done better
there's things that we wish we wouldn't
have
we hadn't done but all in all my summary
is be grateful for what you got don't
necessarily what worried about what you
haven't got did just out of interest in
them Belinda I'd love to get your
thoughts on what you're doing to remain
motivated and things like that because I
think that that can be a real challenge
for people but just a quick analogy
because it's come up quite a lot what so
you mentioned about getting your leaders
to tell you about the good stuff mmm
what is it what what does that good
stuff look like now cuz I feel like it's
it's the small wins that are important
to talk about and communicate right now
whereas maybe three four months ago when
your leaders go or I had I had ten
conversations today that may not have
been as as a good of a win to wear is
now do you I mean so I guess what what
you're in the winds that you've been
celebrating and is that yeah I think
that's interesting
I think we set about anything that's got
potential you know ultimately Europe we
return a lot to mr. recruiters for the
most part that's why we do the job that
we do and that's why we still do it
fifteen years later is that me I've got
this tunnel optimism so we see the best
in everything and the best opportunity
and don't get me wrong I even think free
cab in nineteen it wasn't about the
twenty good conversations or twenty
conversations you heard that day it was
about the one great one you know yes you
know terms of jobs I talk to people
about jobs they've got and I've got
twenty roles and I can't give a monkey's
how many jobs you got the one that
you're gonna feel the one that you can
add value to okay I'm sorry
let me know that that's really changed I
think we're just trying to highlight it
more so all the guys did their reports
at the end of the day and the next day
we celebrate everything every time we
talk about any good stuff that happens
and then we talk about it socially as
well obviously LinkedIn things etc else
you know one of our standards as a
business is celebrate success and
success can mean so many different
things are so many different people so
just celebrate everything because like I
said it's foe bid nineteen or not ninety
percent of time we being told not yeah
at a time we being said yes to then
celebrate yeah I think I think because
I've been speaking to a lot of
recruiters and recruiters there I think
some of the challenges that I've been
here in the law which is interesting is
that good recruiters will know what
outputs they need to do to get them
or have the opportunity to achieve what
they want to and I think I'm seeing the
current market right now the outputs are
you're used to putting in you may be
putting in more you may be putting in
the same amount but there's a good
chance you're not going to get the
outcomes that you that you'd normally
expect and that can be quite difficult
to swallow right that can be difficult
to swallow when you're sat on your
living room table smashing a towel and
these sorts of things so I was just
interested to see I think that's that's
a great force that you have and I think
it is about celebrating those small wins
so I was interested - yes you see we
settled on that everyone needs to remind
themselves that this is going to make
them a better crew to know about the
worst recruiter why don't everyone it's
the other side of this is going to be
way better at their job than ever before
what why because we're going to learn
how to let people we're going to learn
how to manage our expectations we're
gonna like you know talk about more
content we're just gonna become better
at what we do because we're gonna think
about it more because for the last five
years with the great respect and
obviously I'm talking construction
engineering property you've just picked
up the phone and people are giving your
jobs you know and that's been its own
pretty bloody easy at times for the most
part yeah then through this to the other
side it's gonna make us better on who we
are and what we're doing I saw that in
the GFC you know I saw that in the
recession as we call it in the UK where
permanent teams went from 22 to but the
two that survived were way better at it
so I would say remember that continue to
focus on adding value but you'll get to
the other side and I think they'll be
better at this job and that will make
you a better person
well I meant Belinda how have you been
remaining motivated and keeping positive
for the through this period oh like it's
definitely being hard that's for sure
but pre pre covered as you know wearing
recruitment in Australia they call it
razor blades and champagne okay yeah
razor blade champagne right what we call
it in Australia so you have your days
where you know you can pop a champagne
and celebrate but you also have your
days where you just like what is going
on I'm using my mind and that's
literally how I feel on a daily basis
even in curvy but keeping motivated
I'll just add to Andrew I definitely
think it's leaving in the moment
and what's happening now and being
grateful for the good things that are
happening rather than reminiscing or
overthinking the bad things because that
can create negativity on yourself on the
team on the company on the brand and
people can see and feel that and feel
your energy
even if it's just over the phone or a
zoom called people can you know sense
that you're you're in a negative energy
so I definitely think you know being
grateful for the things that are
happening good for you
and just you know meditate do the simple
things go for a walk around the park you
know enjoy nature I take your dog for a
walk read books that you may have in
your house that you haven't read you
know I'm reading the power of now right
now it's a game changer
yeah it's a great book yeah it's a nice
is yeah fire yeah that the the power of
the power of now with the second time a
pizza up I really sort of got with it
but the fur the fur the first part is
quite difficult isn't that to read
sometimes yeah okay living in the moment
and this is this is probably the the
most this is the first time that
probably the meditation has been
mentioned the most amount of times on
that on a recruitment podcast I think
it's great yeah I think I think that's
awesome
I actually love that I think I mean at
the end of the day how many recruitment
business owners would have been speaking
about meditation four or five years ago
you know I mean I'm telling Jason that I
haven't had my kpi's and I need to
meditate and he's going to shut the [ __ ]
off and get back on the phone I think
that's great I think that's absolutely
awesome that you guys are talking about
these things so what what I wanted to
get your guys thoughts on as we sort of
come to the end of this is start sort of
thinking about we're just talking about
it there Andrew and what things might
look like on the other side and how
things are going to change so one of the
questions that Matthew Wilson submitted
and Jason I'd love to get your thoughts
on this and we can go in there so and
this is something that's come up quite a
lot in the
UK as well so what do you guys think
about will more flexible working be
supported to employees now they have
proven some may not proven the their
ability to work remotely is possible or
do you think it would still be a bit of
a he's put taboo subject and I think
just to add to that a lot of business
owners and recruitment or even in your
markets may have had the mindset before
this that now I'd rather my people in
the office I want to see if they're
cracking on and I'd rather that not sure
about flexible working or work from home
but I think a lot of those obviously
their hands being forced right so I
guess Jason what how do you think maybe
we could start with the recruitment
industry or even saw your markets or
what you're seeing how do you think this
all flexible working remote working to
be impacted when we start coming back
out this we no one really knows but I
think if this goes on for another few
more months which it could that second
wave all that sort of thing but I think
it goes on for a few more months and a
few more months or even in another
quarter or so is put through and people
inside of recruitment and outside of
recruitment can sort of prove to really
hold their own
I think that's gonna put a lot of really
interesting pressure on commercial real
estate around the world a lot of people
on speaking to now are saying things
like if projects get delivered or if
people can can really prove that they
can step up to the plate do do what's
asked and even go above and beyond that
that flexible working will most
certainly be an option going forward I
think um for younger recruiters I know
in the recruitment industry there's not
a lot of senior accrued assets that move
from agency to agency as much in the
last sort of five years and we still
gotta you know build your organizations
by by finding juniors and bring fresh to
the industry so I think being around
someone in an office will be somewhat
necessary yeah that takes takes a
scallop we've got a five hundred square
metre office and you know that will
re-sign that when I stood you know this
this is making me here I have it
consider things so a lot a lot of people
be thinking that a lot of people will be
looking at that and going well hang on a
minute do we need all this space could
we did you not I mean I think that's
really interesting okay Andrew what what
do you think and how in terms of yeah
particularly flexible working or just as
a whole in terms of as you start coming
back out of this what your false vision
is to be the most trusted McCrimmon
agency in Australia and so we can't
trust our people then would kind of fail
in at the start of it right and so we've
already had a policy in place related to
performance but I think you know when
working for home yeah yeah yeah
basically we put it on how you know we
can see that you were consistent high
performance and therefore you know we
can have this in place and in fact it
we've had it in place for most of our
senior leadership for a period of time
anyhow and so I hope that we can
implement something that will work not
only for the consultants but the the
business as well I think jason has made
a great point in there you can learn a
lot from podcasts webinars you can learn
from training then you learn the most
from your colleagues on the floor and so
last thing you need to do is remove that
and you know I think is well known that
what is it 80% of training is done in in
the room and don't for one second be
value that is incredibly bountiful I'm
sorry if you do have a work from home
Policy Center awesome be conscious about
how many leaders leaders are at any one
time
because a lot of what I learned was a
call was made I said something or maybe
said something else and then the
leadership the leader would say to what
he picked you know yeah and I said one
thing and in fact I said something
completely opposite to that so there's a
balance and everything in like Jason
said I think the necessary experience
concerns need that support but the more
senior ones do need a little bit of
flexibility but you gotta meet in the
middle because the juniors won't learn
they'll only learn on the seniors so
you'd be very mindful of that that's all
I would say to any business owner
anywhere okay and then obviously blend a
few it seems like obviously the business
that you've been building it it's been
it has been quite flexible and you've
been really open
to not do it in a traditional way so I
guess what were you yeah so I think
obviously which is really interesting so
I guess how yeah your thoughts on
flexible working is it going to stay
like I don't know what would you think
about that I definitely think it will
stay you know speaking to digital
agencies because they're kind of my core
clients and a lot of them are also
giving me the same feedback that we
don't need the big space anymore yeah
our staff are super happy they're
mentally stable you know they're getting
a bunch in and you know getting more
family time and and that's to productive
as well you know obviously the sales and
marketing it's probably a little bit
different because you can't interact
with each other because we're kind of
that personality but I definitely think
we will start to see more of a flexible
workflow for sure and you know as I said
as you guys were saying you know with
productivity it's definitely going to
rise and it has risen for us and for the
agencies for digital agencies for tech
companies and a lot of the engineers and
contractors were already working from
home anyway yeah so because they were
working on certain projects for whatever
they're developing yeah obviously hacks
in your market doesn't that yeah so a I
don't really I can't really say too much
about that because flexibility with
already a thing for us sorry
okay cool so just going under people one
thing from a recurring respective is a
people business you know when we fried
around each other so be mindful of that
in your decision price it's not yourself
a layer I'm just talking definitely be
mindful of that and secondly remember
that whenever you survey people that
Satan what keeps you coming back to work
they would say other people people yeah
yeah we're cutting each other off
let me just really add to that for one
second recruitment like BT the 360
recruiters were all out on the road
anyway meeting
clients and candidates we're never in
the actual office we're having coffees
were having lunches and dinners so I
don't really see you know that I get the
whole you know resourcing and all of
that but a lot of the BD guys in the 360
recruiters they're all out on the road
most of the time you know trying to get
in front of clients and candidates that
can't come to the office to interview
yeah it's really specific isn't it oh
and ultimately you know when you live in
a certain well there's a certain Oh
doing things and I think yeah you're
right in that if you're in check it's
going to be different to help to
different to accounting and finance
different illegal and there's always a
balance and I think that's what I would
say to everyone is just make sure you
you consider the balance between out of
the office and in the office to ensure
that you're meeting everyone's needs
yeah that's a good point and I guess as
we wrap this up there I guess what would
be great to just get all of your
thoughts on Andrea if you go first just
lost Jason but I know Jay yeah well
Jason still was there but we'll work it
out but Andrew and I guess just as we
finish this what what would be your sort
of them parting words to people on sort
of what would you be if everyone
listening right now we're sort of in
your team what would we be saying to
them and for them to be thinking about
over the the next couple of weeks or the
short term medium term what what's your
sort of go-to advice for people to power
power through what's going on and rise
to the occasion
yeah Matt put it earlier actually on one
of the comments where you talk about
short medium and long term goals okay
you've always got to ask yourself and
again pre tribunal may be 19
whatever your long-term goal is every
conversation you have ask yourself is
this atom bound it's that long term goal
because if it's not going to do it um
just focus on that long-term goal okay
bra being the most trusted recruiting
agency so whatever we do in every day
that we do every hour am i doing that or
not doing that because we're not doing
it don't worry about it yeah focus on
that so just focus on the long term go
and make sure what you're doing today is
adding value to that as long as you're
doing that
you're making steps forward every day
yeah I think yeah I think that's a great
point really well Sandra I think I was
awesome I think um yeah I guess so
really think thinking about what ya
really understand why you're doing this
what your purpose is is going to really
help you power from and rise to the
occasion with this right Belinda what
would be your point where's for people
and in terms of getting through this
what the opportunities are what what
people should stay focused on what what
would you say to the people you know I
don't want to get to no no we can hear
you we can hear there's a big delay but
we can hear hello we can hear you yeah
all good hello we've got you so like
what would be your soar poem words to
people on sort of what they should be
thinking about right now what they
should be focusing on what would you say
to people would you advice be for people
to get through this and yeah to power
through what's going on yeah I I keep
adding to Andrea because Andrews making
such good points in theirs I really
think it's about bringing it back to why
you're actually doing what you're doing
and the whole purpose to what you want
to achieve in the market in the industry
and as a person as well I think a lot of
recruiters and a lot of people overall a
lot of people are doing jobs that they
don't really want to do that is doing it
to have an income right and that's the
actual truth and that's why we're in
positions where in but I think
recruiters need to kind of think is that
is this really something that they want
to do and why
what value they can provide I guess
moving forward to create that brand like
it Jason we did leave you for a second
good to have you back so what would be
your your your words of wisdom for
people what should they be thinking
about focusing on IVA next couple of
weeks months what would you be saying to
people I guess firstly understanding if
this is the career of the industry you
really want to be in and I think if
you're not sure or probably the nature
will probably take its cause and sort
that for you but to say something
different because Andrew and Linda both
had really good both had really good
points as a as an owner and I think it's
important if you're able to really
reassure your team I've been fortunate
enough to be that key with the teams
we've got for the next 12 months I know
some other company doing longer or
whatever the case is if set a timeline
in place and give some security and
assurance to your team and I know that
best thing I've done here is over
certain group meaning for me meetings
and we doing mornings and afternoons up
all the time anyway but over communicate
and yeah just got Andrew said you know
great great break your time down don't
only focus on the positives and take it
a day at a time but publicly have a
long-term perspective and don't sort of
listen too much to the media awesome
there's nothing that evil yeah I think I
think that's I think that's great advice
over communicate I think that that
that's that's awesome especially as a
leader well look guys I was a bit
worried at times technical difficulties
but we made it to the end so I guess I
just wanted to take this opportunity to
say a big thanks to Andrew Belinda Jason
for coming on I think you've been really
open and honest can't believe how many
times we've spoken about meditation
mindfulness laughing that's awesome and
yeah I think it's it's been great so let
everyone that's joined those big Frankie
and I hope of you've got some value out
of this and I will definitely plan to do
a couple of more of these as well but it
won't be until a couple of few weeks so
I don't have to wake up as early again
for next couple of weeks which would be
nice but honestly guys thank you so much
all of you and and yeah I just wanted to
say keep going stay safe and we'll get
we'll get through this together so the
big thanks guys